So, we know we need
to create layouts and assets
optimized for different
screen pixel densities and sizes.
So, now's a great time to introduce you
to the Android resource framework.
All externalized Android resources,
everything from strings to layouts,
to drawables and animations,
are all stored within
your project's res folder.
You've already been putting
your strings in the strings.xml file
stored in the values folder.
And you've been putting
your layouts into the layout folder.
And you know to reference
your resources using @ notation
within both your XML
or within the code,
and then at runtime, Android will insert,
the appropriate resource for you.
So far, so good.
And here's where things
get a little more interesting.
Android allows you to create
alternative versions of every resource
by placing them into folders
with different qualifiers.
We separate each of those using a hyphen.
And we add those qualifiers
based on anything
from language and/or dialect,
to whether the device is docked,
the type of touch screen,
the pixel density of the display,
the orientation of the screen,
and most importantly,
for a responsive design in particular,
the smallest available screen width
which you can support with that layout.
At runtime, Android will check
the current device configuration,
it's language, it's screen size,
pixel density, everything,
and then load the right layout strings
and drawables accordingly.
And you can even chain
these qualifiers together.
For example, to create a different layout
for German language users,
to account for all of those
really long German words,
or more typically for a combination
of screen size and device configuration.
Now keep in mind,
that many of these values
can change at runtime.
The most common change
being that of orientation.
And it's for this reason,
that Android activities
are destroyed and recreated, whenever
the device configuration changes.
And that's because the layout
and all of the resources within it
could be completely different
based on something
as simple as screen orientation change.
Now it's good practice as well,
to localize your apps
and provide translated strings
for all of your users
using this mechanism.
And that's a task made a lot easier,
thanks to Google Play Publisher site
that can offer you this service.
It's also a really good idea
to provide different drawables
at the appropriate pixel density,
so you can get a nice crisp image
on every device.
And when it comes to providing
alternative layouts,
Android has gone through
a few alternative models,
starting in the early days,
with this screen buckets idea
of small, normal large and extra large.
But, since Android 3.2,
the new smallest width qualifier
has given us much more
fine grained control over our layouts.